leading nominations like do you really
just walk in here like yeah this is like
we we did that absolutely yeah it's
totally I've totally absorbed it if if
full-on doesn't I forget it is true like
I'll be talking to like a family member
and they'll bring it up and they'll be
like that wait oh that's real now yeah
exactly yeah yeah especially walking
around today in this environment you're
just surrounded by all these incredible
filmmakers that you know many people we
grew up on many people that we Roger
deacons is outside yeah right there he
was sitting in that listener right now
but really it is it is surreal um we've
been saying this whole time that you
know the fact that we even got to make
the movie is was enough that was all we
cared for because even that felt
impossible
um but yesterday I was talking to
Michelle and she was so just happy and
light in a way that I haven't seen her
in a while and she says the fact that we
got this far is already a win let's just
have fun and I was like okay if Michelle
yo says I can have fun now I'm gonna
I'll take that dangerous